dany soir tf1 diffusait le dernier
numéro de cette saison 2 de masques
singer une émission dont le concept est
simple essayer de reconnaître des
célébrités qui sont cachés derrière un
costume des célébrités qui sont parfois
difficiles à reconnaître même sens le
costume
car qu'on se le dise les célébrités
présentes en masse singer ne sont pas
les plus grandes stars de la planète si
en saison une le casting a dépêché pour
cette saison 2 tf1 avait donc décidé de
faire un effort en cachant sous un
costume et une star internationale alors
madonna justin bieber kanye west non
encore plus fou il viard est une
mascarade
et si vous la connaissez sûrement mais
sous un autre masque en dehors de cette
star très célèbre pour les fans de casa
des papes elle les autres célébrités de
masques singer était très célèbre pour
les fans de tf1 car qu'on se le dise
pour leur casting
les équipes du programme sont allés
chercher leurs collègues du bureau d'à
côté comme karine ferri issa doumbia ou
encore valérie damidot finalement la
gagnante de cette saison et larusso une
star que le jury a fait patienter six
épisodes sous son costume de manchots on
a même pensé qu'il avait peut être
oublié
[Musique]
la saison 2 de vastes singer a
enregistré moyenne de 4,9 millions de
téléspectateurs bonnes performances mais
toutefois en baisse par rapport à la
saison précédente alors masstige heures
sur tf1 stop ou encore
alors stop ou encore machine girl en
tête
alors guillaume genton moi j'suis
messenger quoi tu dis stop aussi stop
parce que c'est la pire émission de la
télévision française
actuellement le concept est nul le
casting est nul je comprends pas comment
on peut passer deux heures et demie dans
sa télé a essayé de savoir si sous
l'araignée il ya les bogdanov ou larusso
à charge donc temps pour moi pour moi je
ne comprends pas que la marque
franchement ça et franchement les scores
sont pas mauvais donc je suis vraiment
très étonné que ça marche et je vois pas
l'intérêt des célébrités de faire ça ni
de regarder sa famille des palaces
éloquence tard jean louis mouton dans
ces questions y avait donc est pourquoi
l'argent non pour là aussi on a mahdia
noms avancés avec les stars ya de
l'annonciation ses relations des
meilleurs ce n'est par les médias alors
chaurien si vous avez la passion des
médias change et des bichons jetons
groupe aia rien vous le sait c'est un
bon concept je comprends je suis très
étonné que ça fasse ses scores là on va
prendre nicolas pernikoff un camp
nicolas van persie il a répondu c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est un concept fort
c'est une mécanique de jeu les gens ont
envie de regarder et ça n'est pas
dépendant des gens vous mettez dedans
puisque le casting est plutôt un très
bon et plutôt moyen on va dire à la
saison 1 et 2 et malgré et malgré tout
ça fait 5 millions de téléspectateurs
donc la mécanique de jeu plaît aux
téléspectateurs à dire sans avoir
emmerdé
mais je vous demande un truc qui me dit
la mécanique plaît c'est tout fatigué
terminée madame non je trouve que le
casting le cassis merci à toutes les
femmes sont belles c'est vrai un homme
regarde il dames stéphanie elle était
vraiment les supplie supprimés vous
ressemblez repas kate winslet jodie
edith piaf juste avant
3 la move qui est dans titanic j'ai un
truc à mouiller en plus il ya le
directeur des programmes de ses huit qui
vient de me dire la prochaine diffusion
de titanic sur ces mythes sais pas je
vais bien le vendre le film alors je
voulais vous dire c'est le casting il
est beaucoup trop faible vous rendez
compte quand même que les costumes coûte
plus cher que le salaire des candidats
entre 20004 40000 euros
et en plus ils recyclent les candidats
de danse avec les stars y en a 5 et déjà
et même les candidats ils sont pas sûrs
de vouloir faire l'émission vous avez vu
ce qu'ont déclaré dave et frédérique bel
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont aussi avait pas eu
la crise sanitaire il ne l'aurait jamais
d'accord enfin et sa géométrie marées
alors j'aime lire la renarde c'était
valérie damidot animatrice sur tf1
karine ferri animatrice sur tf1
basile boli qu'a dit la danse avec les
stars ian pollick candidats de danse
avec les stars
issa doumbia participants récurrent de
vettel sur tf1 frédérique bel attristant
demain nous appartient h 24 et nos chers
voisins trois séries sur tf1 donc déjà
casta diva vous dit je vais faire le
cafard pour ma singer est ce que vous
laissez faire
alors moi je ne vais pas dire oui ou non
mais dira non il est au bout de s'abîmer
passe par là
des pays européens où ils l'ont fait en
direct une performance vocale à chaque
fois effectivement c'est bien
intéressant là le fait que ce soit
enregistré c'est pas en direct vraiment
je compose je suis étonné du succès
parce que c'est vrai que ça n'a aucun
sens alors s abaissée le rapport à la
saison une moins 300 mines mais ça tient
bien
il ya beaucoup de gens disent dans le
midi ont été sauvés par le confinement
que oui nicolas pernikoff a battu chalon
il ya eu une augmentation de l'audience
télé 30 minutes
donc forcément il allait plaire alors
qu'ils n'auraient peut-être pas être
regardé je voie le jour
- série de minutes dominaient avec un
ami je finis son abonnement est solide
c'est pourquoi sa mort je peux faire je
voulais qu à notre conseiller clientèle
oui d'accord c'est bon cliquez ici alors
moi je pense sincèrement que le
confinement bas a bon dos parce que dans
tous les cas le pour moi c'est un non
événement cette émission il se passe
rien les gens ne chantent pas pour de
vrai les costumes
en fait on voit juste des beaux costumes
donc à ce moment là si ça plaît autant
aux enfants qu'on le met aussi à une
autre à un autre horaire parce que si on
le met le soir si ça plaît aux enfants
je vois pas trop l'intérêt les lots de
viande et ce serait surtout pas rentable
les marais ou alors est-ce que
l'émission est rentable à un million
jean milot et mentalement je pense
qu'elle est juste en tenant la diane en
histoire à ce sont six à ses 300 400
milles ch pour les parents maximum à 100
400 euros par samedi soir non mais bon
les parents en ce moment non parental
non pas du tout mais pas mais j'y suis
tout à vendre un million 3 je pense 3
c'est sûr que ses parents café parental
enfant ou c'est pas rentable
ça fait plus de 50% sur les 15/34 m
vanhecke se demande un million trois
cent vingt heures au pub tue par soirée
je pense c'est impossible mais je
passais pas cas alors c'est une vraie
question là que je vous pose
oui on sait pas que la pub sur les
gosses comme 55% des 4-10 ans regarde
excellent quand c'est bourré de pub de
gamins pour noël pensais pas que ça peut
jouer rejoint un million trois cent
mille ma chérie je vois pas comment ils
les sortent en pub sur mass singer je
sais qu'il ya trois écrans pub par
émission sept minutes recomptés même si
ces 50 me serais bien passé cinquante
mille euros l'écran on va dire qu'il ya
dix écrans pub ça arrive cinq cent mille
avait paru que ça ferait un million et
demi et là vraiment on est là donc c'est
comme un rêve c'est vraiment ces flammes
ont animé je pense que les musulmans
étaient très très longue oui elle était
très longtemps après tomber laurent
ruquier d'ailleurs
j'ai adoré quoi qu'on dise c'est quand
même le plus gros coup que tf1 ait fait
céder à ces derniers temps avec leurs
émissions aujourd'hui qui c'est qui peut
se vanter de dire je fais 5 millions de
moyenne avec une émission à koh lanta ça
à koh lanta shopping r c'est fait pour
les enfants c'est rigolo faire la
justice une femme et qui sont déguisés
et caen avec ans guillaume midi cette
émission elle sert à rien allait nulle
années lula urbains ils insultent
quelque part un peu et respectable que
tu peux pas trouver 5 millions de noms
mais c'est quand même compliqué au bout
d'une semaine sera d'accord de semaine
même à singer c'est déjà la deuxième
saison et ça tient cinq on a droit
d'avoir un avis critique sa mission
c'est pas ça marche que le loft story
quand ça cartonnait ya plein de gens qui
disent ça va cartonner en pâture à des
gens qui disent que tpb c'est damir non
mais juste dire le goût alors non mais
tu vous dire sur les 5 millions dur moi
je vois beaucoup de temps aussi sur
twitter qui disent on regarde pas ce que
ça vanne degré bien sûr on est nicolas
veut pas venir le contraire autant le
concept de the voice on doit deviner des
candidats à l'aveuglé il ya une
philosophie des relais mission c'est que
le physique ne compte pas y a que la
voix qui compte là c'est quoi le concept
de deviner qui est qui que larusso et
derrière la renier sa foi c'est de
l'aider à l'école d'abord il n'ya plus
rien le samedi soir en télévision mais
c'est françois s'écouter et du
divertissement le divertissement de
samedi soir qui le tenait déjà vu un
truc sébastien scenner soir sur france 2
et à l'époque elle est un petit peu
d'événementiel d'ailleurs vous allez
regarder un des comas stinger va se
terminer
bon il y aura the voice a abandonné et a
gardé qu'il arpente les bras il risque
d'aller de plus en plus vers la fiction
pour essayer de continuer à surperformer
le samedi soir mais personne empêche les
chaînes de proposer des programmes il
fait pas payer sa radio s'arrête alors
non mais ça reste audacieux ils ont pris
un risque on a parlé le trail c'est sûr
est ce que vous auriez fait pas son nom
et ce quand je l'aurai fait non pas 5
millions de téléspectateurs les donc
bravo effectivement fait ça mais ça va
venir les frais après faut voir il faut
voir faut voir si ça tient en 3e série
parce que moi je vous dit s'il ya une
concurrence en face ça peut être plus
compliqué mais regardez 11,2 qui est
quand même très très haut regarder sans
excès il en référence soit scellé génie
tué on pensera aussi cdg m des rediff
c'est quand même des signes
oui gagnant 0,5 million seller on va
revenir c'est vrai les hauts risques
excusez moi il ya zéro l'émission
cartonné partout ailleurs basse et une
prise de risques annonce sa marge et par
souci alors ben non mais attendez c'est
un format alternatif l'informatique
partenaires ont les pays d'europe que
bakiev oklahoma qui cartonne à
l'étranger n'en prend garde rien on
jubile 5 millions 10 à la gironde
expliquer quelque chose niveau de la
télé monsieur qui vient des fruits zenit
que j'adore mon chéri et f1 qui peut
l'acheter un million trois cent mille
euros le bout tu ne peux pas l'acheter
ailleurs voilà c'est pour ça qu'on est
là et tf1 après peut-être qu'il ya m6 un
moment qui pourra aller vers ce genre de
programme là où ça devient très très
cher pour tf1 non pas bien sûr certaines
de même souffert de l'inquiétant c'est
même pas sûr qui s'est impliqué à ce
prix là parce qu'un million trois cent
mille roux je vous dis ils sont ils sont
à zéro voilà il son flat ne gagnent pas
d'argent week-end après vous avez posé
tout à la main question du confinement
sur le fait que ça fasse de bonnes
audiences moi je pense que déjà
premièrement oui le confinement ça fait
des bonnes audiences mais aussi le fait
que les stars entre guillemets soit
aussi en confinement je pense que c'est
ça aussi où elles se disent bah oui mais
je veux montrer un peu saoul c'est donc
ils ont tourné à l'affrontement à leur
honneur
exactement c'est ce qu'a dit fait
dériver la d6 j'avais pas et en
confirmant j'aurais jamais elle a fait
plaisir à l'élection pour l'émission a
déjà aussi parce que j'ai eu mes potes
dedans meyer qui va là bas avec moi dans
la grosse rigolade avec gad elmaleh
voilà comme ça rien non non non c'est
même pas sa grande carrière et dont vous
connaissez mieux mais c'est fanny boîtes
à savon